hello everybody I went back to the home
screen yes sorry guys I was a part of
our little continued version rich here
go please person ever has before they're
so rich he's just here to watch me get
boots but yes hope you enjoy our
ambience we have even turned out the
lights a little bit in here spooky vibe
yeah we wanted maximum spook factor uh
so yeah thank you guys for joining us we
actually really just wanted to start
playing already so that's why we're a
little bit early we're hyped super and
yeah so we kind of just got through the
very beginning part that was a lot of
just like walking in cutscenes and
nothing really scary yet yeah a little
walking as Ritchie mention like I
haven't played this one I've seen you
know other people play it and I've
watched like some of my favorite
youtubers play it but I've never had to
translate he has so he's gonna very much
enjoy me getting scared I may be helped
out a little bit if needed
hey chat what's up everybody spooky
hello from Houston Texas Alan I was just
in Houston that's cool
Sammy let's do this let's get scared
yeah alright so right I did see a figure
walk by when we were walking here and
then he disappeared so yeah now we're uh
let's start yeah
first I got a crash course of the story
we are playing Ethan the role of Ethan
we're looking for our girlfriend Mia I
have no answers Allen Hey oh my goodness
y'all I can't it's dark it's so good I
have a flashlight I'm scared already
you do okay DJ yeah
remember when Michael Hardy and Mary
Kish would play this or they played it
in VR also good times also hello from
the Philippines he says did this have a
beta or like a teaser version of the
crew yes it did it did had a demo okay I
think I played the demo yes Raymond this
is such a good Resident Evil I'm just
gonna agree wholeheartedly it's just
it's just good it's scary and good it
changes it up like so well didn't go
over the top it was just the right
amount of scary even the ambient noises
Matt madness why was I think to come
here fall hey glad you're here stick
around if you like Resident Evil 7 yeah
there was my flash like out Adam yes to
answer your question yes yes yes and the
heavy breathing from my character does
not know that just me yeah Ethan is as
nervous as you are / yeah turning around
in these games actually just scares me
to no end
can you quick turn by pressing like down
and something I guess not the things we
do for love
Thank You DJ he says good luck Tomb
Raider says hi hey what's up thanks for
joining
so you'll see these along the way these
are your save points
ah okay sure why not
I think it auto saves too but in a
Resident Evil game you can never be too
safe chat what's going on it's your
favorite resident let me know
this is probably one of my I think
number two and number two's remake is my
favorite this is a close second this is
so good
there you go Matt you do love resi
you're in the right place rend it was
fate that you um I played oh I didn't
play the Rema remake so I did play some
I'm I think I play Resident Evil 1
actually I played some an older Resident
Evil with Ben he's really really good at
it but I've mostly played four and five
four let's go oh those are my feet and
they are you're stepping on like drywall
hey param what's up good to see you
again go here now that I have this tape
hüseyin hey what's going on thank you
guys for joining
well we'd Emily well about the head the
guys a nice manicure though there you go
wait is this the same of course creepy
TV you apply it annoying creepy clues
creepy everything Oh unsettling picture
Tomb Raider oh that's my wife I think
that looks like me huh huh we're getting
[Music]
mad asks who's your - who's your to know
who's your favorite resin evil character
from the two of us his is bare Wesker
Wesker I think I like Chris like I like
Chris Redfield then probably Leone more
I love Leon he's good guy good guy
it's cop good cop remember his first day
on the job was protecting Raccoon City
in part two
oh okay little little tape here where
did you find this guy
give me a break Pete hey I only work
with professionals speaking of which
Skeeter the sound is right this time I
don't want a repeat of Amarillo that was
two [ __ ] years ago
I don't do ADR this new guy
not feeling it
[Laughter]
we do a walk through the inside first
then we shoot the intro always were they
were there at yeah Adam four or five
we're definitely like Action shooters so
that's like like the other ones are more
creepy to me cause like what I'm used to
is just kind of just like action and
like shoot the zombies up yep that's all
five is good for that yes let's go yeah
good job guy you were see ya so all this
time you know this is actually cool that
they like you'd be the cameraman you're
like yeah you're in control
[ __ ] me how was it anchor you know we
can sub Pete not anchor what say no I
say what I motive what's the story Andre
abandoned farmhouse missing family foul
play suspected the usual
I haven't played Blair Witch but that's
a good buddy should've been here three
years let's make a great cut away so uh
hillbilly Jonah's family go missing not
hillbillies the baker's jack and
Marguerite Baker the backward a lot of
bad rumors about their son Lucas bad
seed apparently Philly Prince are we i
had my shots although just to make a
great backdrop ah Dre what do you think
Andre Oh
we just lose our home me Andre no no it
was fast
Clancy you see where Andre went look
away for a second nor just to recap
we're looking for that guy I mean
producers they call it go but a good
cameraman like you Clancy no yeah me now
we're chums nice kitchen right now Adam
the one with the red disks was Resident
Evil 2 for sure on the ps1 loved it did
you hear that what did you see that a
little flicker in his flashlight yeah
[Music]
that's a Roger I know I'm in this room
[Applause]
are you man
he ain't in here we heard something
though what wasn't here oh you found a
trapdoor and just find Andre there we go
I mean [ __ ] this show
Oh Ellen you're right I did have two
tiny discs on GameCube also I remember
that this ain't gonna end well so these
guys died
I don't think I've ever went backwards
like this need a nice hero shot of me
coming down the ladder he has no idea
what's going on down there he's like
straight up on me this time I'm really
gonna beat it I like how you look down
first like I know it's Mark Zuckerberg
he's cool God they really wanted me a
lot of good
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'm glad nothing like really bombed
on it seven a funny homeboy in the
coronary Jesus hmm
now we're back we are ethan once again I
know Tomb Raider says I have all the
Resident Evil games and movies whoa
I don't even have all of them well you
know you know what to do you saw the
same not what I would be doing by the
way
hello mr. Connors are mcaren artist says
he he says this game was made for VR
yeah I don't think I'd survive if I went
by myself I would try VR Oh sometime has
a ladder since that bodies are gone but
you know there's still blood on the hook
Oh yep chat keeps going there like you
must play this on psvr we know we know
an impact hard to streaming a little
harder to stream is that sweet by you
water straight line the moon Persia I
know you freaking out
[Music]
you are dodging you really it's the wall
Mia are you down here in this room
honestly if you put me through something
like this divorce over I don't say whew
oh that means something is about to
happen to me what was that also
Canterbury turned dad turned dad dad dad
dad Clancy doe L you just think that L
lost Oh
this list is mmmm no bueno
what was my girlfriend's name the enemy
amia undetermined
you two should each play by ourselves in
a dark room at night what are you doing
doing you should both have a heart
attack
there's two of us for a reason come
prepared there we go yeah me alone
thank God I found you it's me it's
evening season season are you alright
you shouldn't be here
Oh what do you mean not a Hello your
concert no no I wouldn't
did I well I did buy so stay away do
they want to see you did he see you
who else is here what the hell's going
on
daddy's coming we need to go we need to
go now bad sign I mean your hair looks
real nice for you being captain must be
in the genes where are you taking me
someplace safe are you gonna tell me
what's going on baby you've been gone
three years three years has it really
been three years she can't believe it
Ethan is like a champ he's a hero
let's get out of here right hmm
playing too much girl rope turn off your
flashlight its kid no don't what what is
this place what they do you not now we
need to get out of here first I think
it's this way you've been here for three
years girl I think you need to know
where we're going by now oh don't like
that operating table chair gurney thing
no thanks cans
Oh me we have to talk that message you
said not me
that wasn't me what you did I didn't
okay fine just tell me what's going on
I'm telling you everything that I know
at least look at me okay dark creepy
hallway check family used to bring me
food through here
I remember Jordan Jones thank you for
playing this game one of my faves no
name
happy spooky season yeah awaits know
your lots been women me there it's there
this game is good hundred what I'm sure
of it
creepy doll alert yeah that's a big no
it's go and if I look over there and
it's gone one day I'm the old world
family now that you're here let's hear
that now we're gonna be a family now
that you're here I'm sure she's she's
tripping out
yo hold up for the count
oh oh you want me going here with this
place creepy doll who Ellen says man so
Oh Oh God
oh you're we're hype to Alan modern
warfare does come out today enjoy the
door it reopened oh oh
grant me a thumbnail granny granny man
man she got picked up your fakes ones
last have you blink for a blink all the
way up
[Music]
my gun in here
they look around that's not a bad idea
everything's a bad idea
please well we need a gun disconnected
takes too long but then everything's
just so scary honey no it's okay
thank you I'll thank you for joining us
hope you're enjoying the stream okay
got a map there we go Jordan you just
preaching to the choir my friend yep I
agree with everything you say that's why
I thought it'd be perfect for stream
plus Persia hasn't played it yet thank
you Bob Jones we just got here we don't
want to jump out the window
I mean if I could I would really mean on
your own girls we did way too much I'll
board it up anyway would it be spooky if
I talked it would either relate helping
me keep my sanity good hello from
Baltimore Maryland love this game [ __ ]
phonetic you're in the right place man
thank you for joining us
yeah join us until Halloween spoon yeah
okay I'm like scared and it makes my
brain work way less that's when I that's
when I get that's what I can't even
think right now
yes a spooky quite funny no this isn't
new dlc we're just playing the good old
resident evil 7 purges first time thank
you for joining us and I'm ready love we
heard some some crazy knocking yeah we
need some answers
oh you know what there was some drawers
back here I think I didn't like very
nice of you
meanwhile I played this game back and
backwards and forwards and I'm like
they're a key secret door
[Music]
Elijah Brown it is really fun and really
scary
did that doors like not open when you
try to shove it no
I don't get the hand animation when I
walk up to my door
I miss I miss something didn't I maybe
yeah maybe some backtracking can be
useful
Jordan says yep it's her first time I
love watching new ones for the first
time always exciting welcome to the van
yeah Darren I think you're right you may
need to go back to the basement there
was one more room next to the room or
Mia got snatched in that other room I
think there might be some stuff Eliza
Brown we're doing good Trey its diverse
time it's restraining order time baby
let's go this is domestic violence
imagine this in VR right now alright
in here I can feel her Klein version is
still pressing resist oh yeah you do you
think Mia yeah I think you got this
under control
it wasn't me officer there you go very
important tip there you go Oh give me
the juice yeah Mia you gotta go well
that's one way to unlock the door are
you
yeah I'm trying
[Music]
of course I gotta do that they gotta
turn her normal as she dies I know I
know
kill it with napalm seriously what part
of the game are you guys in we just
started we just entered the Baker family
home
lordy Lordy you know come huh who's this
and what the [ __ ] is going on this
should be a way out through the attic
attic oh that
now that's bait Bob Jones Wow first a
delivery works very good on severe knife
wounds
that's video game logic baby you know
bad times already through this hallway
why our haunted house is always so big
there's like a million floors 20 rooms
yep attics and basements whoo poor
fanatic it's worse playing in the dark
by yourself trust me I've been there but
it's also like an unforgettable
experience with headphones on - where's
the pulley rope like in the movies I
know
Hey
don't make me think right now a game
like I can't my brain doesn't work oh
wait
like a button of course it's got to go
turn the power up now engineer please
why they put me do this all right we got
a I remember there being a fuse box oh
god this is a bad again okay
god I'm scared to turn around okay a way
of wire cutters now or whatever you bolt
cutters Omari says your fingerprints
were at the scene of the crime nice all
right got the fuse did you see that you
saw that I think you know where to go
haram says you need a camera fully
focused on Persia's face because her
reactions are so funny
ding where was that fuse box I was it
down here was it upstairs
it was downstairs well no harm in
looking in the rest of this floor
oh it was right here okay Sidharth eric
is around he's uh he's busy working
editing you know running around doing
this and that but he is still here with
us at GameSpot for sure can't check your
corners guys a Mollison I was prepared
to run up the stairs you shouldn't have
done that girl you need to see someone
about this
you know I think mental health awareness
this happened I'm we're gonna see about
getting me up some real help
oh yeah serious you don't have a
chainsaw Wow
okay now we're good resist
[Music]
it was a great cackle straight up my she
wanted a divorce
so you didn't even take the ring off she
took the whole head can I take it back
up and put it back on I guess you can oh
well you can pick it up I'm definitely
dying right now
I have no fire to cauterize is that the
word this cauterize the wound I should
have used my stub to preserve it
well at least Persia Randall says thank
you guys
you're helping me get through my paper
I'm glad my shrieks of Terror are
helping you Amari says divorce
counseling yes
hey gun okay he's had enough you how can
you [ __ ] it with one hand
three loaded the door closed
like I'll write when I decided to run
earlier she grabbed me
oh mannequins nice sneaky mannequins are
number one in a horror game [ __ ] move
please
yeah thanks programmers
I'm dead no no you got this
oh god no god I can't oh
[Music]
have you loaded one hand Jesus Ari she's
never panic shooting I like could not
aim
wait do I relay dania all I did was love
you there's a three years I couldn't
find your ass smiling at me whoopee you
know guys when when we tell you you
should listen to us it's not because we
you know are lying to you it's because
we don't want you to die
no your guiding you yeah we're lis back
to the nub no gun okay I'm sunny right
now I wouldn't be able to do any of this
my hand gun Amal Ibiza wow she even saw
the beam nice detail
yeah very good I'm mad I walked up the
stairs and like it took me forever to
get back down yeah you know where you
are now oh there's bullets behind you
don't forget oh yeah I got that now load
of hookahs we going all right let me get
my heart rate down so I can I actually
listen and aim my heart rate is that
yeah
got it for you
aigo controllers gettin crazy ain't even
our chan woo F's in the chat all the s
you did better though you got a lot more
headshots in cheese I'm not going down
easy
Nate's games back in the building Connor
baby you got real ugly oh yeah you know
what I actually keep forgetting I can
sprint because I get so scared and that
that little eel stuff although she gets
so close to you so quickly yeah I gotta
move Oh Mari thank god I'm single
now I'm just frantically good you know
what to do you're ready now you got this
Persian well one step all right now
get away from me crazy can I say the
shooting here once you come down or
invincible up here I would wait for that
animation to finish anywhere good luck
there you go get some distance
I would even let her finish up
[Music]
no you don't chop my hand off crazy yeah
take that change
oh Jesus not a bad gaming technique just
kick that away from you give it up chat
whoo Lord Oh God get me out of here out
that Conor I don't disagree
the mechanics might be a little slow but
that makes it a family son okay you got
knocked up yeah
welcome to family son head butt or no
your head in I need it great
after that you're doing great there you
go
thank you mr. pebble oh no look un dia I
decide to like calm down for a second
David young yep I remember that from the
commercial even welcome to family son
[Music]
yeah the demo is definitely much
different unless that's like from a
different part of the game one don't you
die on us now you have work to do they
stapled my hand back on and gave you a
you're alive there you go Barak well
done thing here got it and you know like
sometimes in the re games they get this
weird like animation after they get shot
where they're invincible right so it's
also like figuring out when that's over
yep
you did good though you kept your
distance in that last fight oh it's time
for supper meet the family where's Mia
she's dead yeah I know how that feels
I've been there done that
fatty eat supper you didn't even close
me there was no seasonings have no song
on there look at that Flynn Flynn Boyle
okay
this is actually all new it is cloud
interesting kilogram my supper yeah let
me borrow those wheels real think I
gotta get out of here
you're tied down to this chair Nate's
games chill woman yeah that lady was
correct there you go you better be in
there okay I was like you better be in
that seat when I turn around I was like
something that really creeps me out I
was like surprised like they disappear
out of nowhere
stacking newspapers
yeah we need like 20 pet collars that's
why wait that's still what's a wallaby I
don't trust that dead grandma I know
seriously nope no knives you got this
birthday man everything's locked garage
oh thank you okay thanks
I fix the power can be removed by a hint
that's some strong today that is cloud
no spoilers well we won't be playing
like all day but we're the beginning
really so that we could play longer yeah
this whole place on lockdown oh thanks
he still thinks you're sitting at the
table grandma gone she rolled out in the
there was a you're right in the garbage
can I think it was a little herb like
hard right
oh boy all right and goes it's a nice
out of here anyway
big old super lock where's your old
curled up I don't I'm not even gonna
look behind me I don't care I just gonna
slow me down I'll give you a hint yeah
you need a knife and it's somewhere here
in here no no you you know not to break
those open but I forget where exactly
and here it is you gotta like you have
been making check like every drawer
[Applause]
[Music]
dodge them
[Music]
yeah there was my Andrew it's from
gripping the run got this the hatches
over here Adam asks you have psvr
we do here in the office but we didn't
set it up for stream no if we could Oh
[Music]
creepy crawl space
give me a night
he better not buzz down here I was in
crazy shams he's so mad I went and found
this key just gonna break the ground
Nate asks who the hell says howdy
someone chasing with a freaking axe and
cowboys
yes a spy your shoulders unclean
absolutely minder for those in chat this
is purchase first time plane she's doing
great
you know when I when the beginning look
familiar and I realize I did like try
the demo back in the day right it was
definitely nothing I forgot I had a map
in store items all I have is one oerba
okay two herbs to open the door
little little breather Daniel hey what's
up thank you for joining we're doing
great
why am persons freaking out a little bit
oh oh yeah wait is he gonna come answer
that oh it was in that room you were in
oh the phone was behind you oh I guess I
should because she's probably gonna tell
me something yeah I forgot last time
that they actually told me is something
useful so we don't alert homeboy right
you got to get out of that house
no [ __ ] make your way out through the
main hall all right Oh first the anti
thing on your wrist is it codex don't
lose it it's important look at those
stitches oof
cloud says you're doing great for a
first run right oh thank you I don't
even put it on easy easy mode or
anything there you go there you go
watching I will be able to get through
every door I can use that on tape Oh
Nate says I saw it too underground when
you were crawling through underground
you missed something but it was it was a
coin it was one of those upgrade coins
so I can upgrade stuff later on yeah so
right now it's not urgent but if you
ever
go back down there you can pick it up no
biggie though you're back in the hallway
[Music]
I really can't use a lockpick that is
whack you know break it with my rage I
don't know where it is yeah that's extra
play actually like so shocked because
everything I
hmm it's like a part of that clock is oh
the tables gone
yeah he's smashed remember yes oh yeah
Oh Adam psvr works see can I put it on
and use the controller yes you can
yeah you can some games you can use
those those VR controllers with the
lights on top but for this game you can
put on the headset and play with the
controller and you look around with your
head hey Austin thanks for joining us
ke 23 also hello this is Persia's first
time ding it's all right mm-hmm
oh I forgot there was something that
needed to be kicked right like uh some
yeah I ran up to a bunch of locked saw
earlier you're about to get stabbed in
the back as you go we can feel it what
me no no all right now we got several
calls about some missing persons late
you understand I gotta get out of here
calm down
you're not listening to me there are
crazy people in this house trying to
[ __ ] kill me all right he's about to
die so who's gonna be laughing in a
second persons who's gonna be a class
and I can't rule out that an outsider
like yourself may not be involved all
right I'll tell you whatever you want
all right
now that's more like now meet me in the
garage
we'll talk hey wait you gotta give me
your gun right that's even a stretch
officer dick right deputy how do you
want to see my name in the obituaries
hey you want to be a hero and save my
life a [ __ ] pocketknife
here's very nothing dude take it I mean
you were crazy Danny the guy in the each
other go Thanks good night David hmm
hope you don't have any nightmares yeah
it says good luck with the Baker's yeah
yeah there you go what's in here
good always need those real quick yeah I
don't know why they highlight that sign
let's say you extra now yeah that's
super tape now his hand works they cut
it works hey we gotta get the [ __ ] out
of here now first you need to tell me
what you're doing out here alone in the
middle of the night me what about you no
it's my job once you do your job and
tell me answer my questions yeah how can
I believe me if I told you try the door
Susan
scoop out of his brain hurry you are not
playing let's try them out here turn in
tight ones you got the project
guard guard what is yes yes okay kid
it's courage honor
you got it I got it
oh I hit L to you that was my own
actually oh you lived l1 is great yeah
oh it's like epic card is Drive resist
run amok
you better go
reassurance today kitten
I want to ram the door what do you think
oh let's finish this you and I we gotta
get out we gotta get out no I'm alive
I'm still looking whoo wizard this is
not the eat are the hardest mode this is
purchase first time we went chat said to
check out that workbench combine items
Connor says is your great time for her
is a good job for your first plate thank
ya I'm terrified
alright peach Trevor Trevor from GTA a
he's got that same haircut let's buddy
Fernando okay oh wait
okay okay gotcha um he's definitely not
dead so how do I get out of here oh
there's a ladder nice I forget that
comes down like don't do this to me yeah
come on all right let's climb welcome to
thing Persia I mean I know you've not
dead oh I just for the door it's for the
door I need that I need that yeah down
there huh you guys got a clue there or
you got a piece
well that shutter door open no just
checking the temperature of all right
maybe there was a door up your hands
yeah oh yeah oh wait
or another oh there we go
I got the piece for the door oh man too
slow to wake up okay every time they do
that I'm convinced let's get on hand to
something crazy yeah run faster even we
guys lying for this is this spring yes
yeah I'm gonna turn the same he's gonna
be there I got it I got it let's be fair
you're doing great uh-huh I was really
hoping I'd be outside right now yeah
like that was the front door
there's a front door that one look like
multiple pieces behind you by the front
door the cup the pro strats from Zoe
cloud call a medic for the cotton yeah
no way
that's your father oh boy I'm sorry but
he he he said he's dead now we just not
be able to pull this off
what pull what off there's something I
need you to do but I can't explain it
right now you may need some sort of keys
to do it but find a way out of the house
okay I'll be in touch he's in here my
gosh yeah oh yeah what is that a very
special key for that door I see but
you'll know when you find it
Oh granny's already upstairs posted up
oh no Oh classic Resident Evil all right
guys here take it back anymore one
bullet anyway we'll switch that over
something else later like old classic
Indiana Jones I really don't like granny
she hasn't done anything to me but I've
seen enough
another special key it's like a snake
dead snake Allen with the spongebob
quotes no daddy yes okay can't get it on
protect for safety I would just toss
myself through here and run they boarded
it up they made that impossible
creeping around the corners there's a
little box there though you got that
knife
no more lock picks on a mallet blow it
up yeah sure
creepy bathroom classic that's that's
good news yeah I probably should drain
in it
hey if it's anything like old resident
evil okay statues are a good sign yeah
oh my gosh that's the 180 switch yeah I
didn't realize that was so helpful it's
nice in circle okay good but I thought I
was getting grabbed by something in it
turn that camera around so should beat
the hell out of Diane be enough kind of
a cool power though yes generation oh my
little girl has given us a gift and this
gift
you can stay over there which in a word
means I stated I Stanley yeah you got to
start this frame my cheek sir you have
any help potions you're fully healed but
I don't remember
holy swinging I mean he's closed his
books he's close
Persia is sure oh my gosh secretly I was
waiting for that because I knew that
happen well joke's on him you gave me
another way out
black ASIS don't look back I'm not I'm
not I know that's the it's the first
mistake run Forrest run
forget the mixture for first aid kit but
you do have an herb you can eat that by
itself it gives you a little bit of hope
but if you mix it you know other things
can I eat once I'm gonna see if I could
see I don't have any more tapes oh yeah
I mean I thought I'm already over her
hour yeah now we're just looking out for
us trying to live oh look what it's
called yeah Daniel that was a very
shining moment here's Johnny dude busted
through the wall I know I can't expect
anything from you not after what
happened you're what I did but I just
want you to know that wasn't me I don't
I don't know what happened
there's so much that you need to know
there you are you gave us quite a scare
young lady
we ship at the camera she's using both
hands Oh creepy barnyard small child
alert oh and the giggle nah we're out my
child I teach my children better you
know grounded Lisa wasn't you died
you're doing great I think I died way
much like I died way more on my first
playthru Jack I think got me a bunch of
time dad you can still kill you for
watching the tape oh boy that's not cool
I hope that's not true
I ran through here mark wheeler says I
just got the platinum edition of
Resident Evil 7 and I really enjoyed it
looking forward to the next generation
of re games first sure that platinum
edition has everything all the DLC you
made the right choice
[Music]
all right all right see him please go
away oh there it is now they give you
the quick turn pro tip the quick time is
kind of scary yeah you got scared the
first time when you accidentally did it
man I mean everything else is locked
she doesn't know where you are she'll
see me
I think she might go this way and then
you go for
I don't understand you at all this
I think she opened that door that you
know was locked we are all run but now I
know where it is that's true
Thank You Pharaoh he says hi and good
luck Burgess rest in a little bit this
is her first time playing Resident Evil
7 it's dark
am I going anywhere nope thank you yeah
girls bout to die
you weren't able to pick that thing up
that's what I did but it didn't like I
know you I know you were scheming
scheme
it's definitely a little makeshift plane
there but it's missing pieces
Wow yep you're right
Wow when the chat says I played this
game 20 times that little girl becomes
much more important later we're thinking
like the same thing yeah go away stop
oh go left first I can run
[Music]
come on was there another door chad is
like wait just wait I forget maybe I
should have stayed outside
oh yeah since the chat delay she's got
I'm sorry guys I made a mistake she's
dressed all right um I'd be so dead IRL
unless that other door unlocks once she
left is that thing still not I can't
pick it up
I saw her light all right John I'm
hiding out back here again I can only
assume this is a part of the you know
see that thing
I don't know if you can at this point
pick it up but maybe move it around oh I
can pick it up now you can't at first he
couldn't okay I gotta - this is fun
yep a spider like a here once you have
it you think you just press like X if
it's like close enough I don't remember
making like a do like a sound if you get
it right okay
you're way out here Thank You Chad
they're like yep man they're gonna bust
you those well I can it's so narrow I
hate this imagine this in VR no nope
Nair paneer paneer Connor I hate spiders
so scary Adam the the spider thing is a
similar puzzle to the shotgun but where
is she
the controller was going out of control
you made a lot of progress though man
this tape is like its own side mission
goodness back at it geez
probably starts from that little spot
yeah I hope so
give us a break here mm Wow says I did I
played this game in VR it's a good one
great song brave souls all right I just
got a like hey you're here okay good
you're not didn't push you back this is
where that little girl was you're on the
other side of that room yeah I'm glad
she's not here right now
cloud oh I don't big same I think I have
to activate her coming out of the thing
first yeah oh yeah
babji's yeah yeah it's dark out here all
you have to do is accept our [ __ ]
gift so rude
ice david dahveed says get a bazooka and
kill only huh we have a little pocket
knife I'm good
you're good yeah little pathway down
there well there was something down
there oh where do you think you're going
sitar thanks what day is today out of
the 8 days of this is number 4 the
number 4 we unfortunately lost day
number 2 did day number one with Silent
Hill 2 and then day number 3 was what we
play yesterday I forgot already oh oh
the evil within Yeah right yeah man this
part it takes a lot yeah some heavy
loading here but um what are you
thinking so far about this game it's
good it's good cuz it's catching me in
ways that are just like I'm just so
eager to like escape yeah and I know
they're always around me so it's just
like heightened fear the entire time
it's it's cool but it sucks cuz like
even in tense situations or you're
always supposed to like be on the
lookout for things like I don't have
time I'm running away from somebody like
I'm not looking for a key I know I do
need to
this is giving me some good buffer time
this loading screen
I better not come back and have homeboy
in my face with like an axe though
because that's not the business too much
okay okay
cloud asking Resident Evil 2 remake I
did scary yeah I'm hearing footsteps oh
you can't go down they've been destroyed
but that's where you were earlier I
believe when the game started okay
George granny Shane over here she's cool
she's cool granny is spying on yes my
she's Adam Resident Evil Resident Evil
has always been Capcom games Silent Hill
I believe was Konami but they're similar
especially the early days yeah your
knife oh you saw that gun too but you
know what
just yeah maybe just try to get away
you're doing great I feel like I don't
wanna there is right there I should just
see ya times is right there I can join
you I can't Liars
there's granny I lost them I lost nice I
don't hear him anymore
oh there is his weapon just keeps
changing every time it was like an axe
now it's like this but I don't like how
he's standing there though and where did
his shirt go okay you know you got hot
yeah we out here things always family
Oh what our who they're referring to
okay maybe now we can explore downstairs
in peace yeah hey how he's like
lingering he hangs out
Wow asked will you play the Resident
Evil 7 DLC probably not today oh you can
jump down the steps a sec well there was
an herb there if you're interested on
that little table over there oh nice
look you can bust those if you want you
get a trophy if you're knocking all out
but some of them are hard to find
hey I think you know what to do
oh but you have the piece yes I got this
puzzle master this is probably not the
piece or is it the piece oh yeah yeah
had to be like flipped like all the
directions mouth part I think there's
the beak he's upside down oh you got
this oh oh
kind of Oh totally cut it close enough
right
all right this house is wild too full of
traps and puzzles and exactly yeah Oh
arrow says makes me remember when I had
a wrist when I had resident evil Code
Veronica for the Dreamcast yeah that's a
great game that was like the last like
classic style Resident Evil game
Wow says get ready for the mold yeah
wish I could have closed that door
behind me yeah that would have been yeah
forgot about those psychostimulants just
make more noise counteract y'all's
creepy noises oh I'm in a safe place ah
I think wait is there a safe thingy I
think you hear music one no I'm not sure
I forget in this game there is good save
music but I'm not sure here nope no no
no no kid drawings
yeah make me open yeah I guess this is
the mall you're dying of man what
Oh God Rosie okay your first encounter
with the mole yeah I was like creepy
venoms brother yeah I'm sweaty you guys
Julie we're doing great how are you oh
thank you for asking Julie yeah little
pressed chat even just dropped in right
now there you go that's how you make
full-blown healing potion the first 8
mins healing potion wrong game you can
tell when your screen with like red on
the corners I wanted to move it over to
my other quick spot but that's fine and
now your watch says you're in green and
good health oh nice
Alan asks do you guys think resident you
will eight or another remake will be in
the works for 2020 I'm hoping Resident
Evil eight first honestly they have like
a killer formula so I wouldn't doubt
they got something in the works
here we go again oh shoot oh no do the
quick turn there you go
that sounded good jeez oh I got a hold
down on the analog and do it okay I
didn't mean it's just brought over my
menu that's fine
Adam the one with the alligator was
Resident Evil 2
very scary moment yeah cloud says
raising evil to all so that's that was a
big moment in that game very fun things
enough thing to worry about we've got
like okay who is safer out there we go
that's that tune in clues
just another another soul here I like
that everyone's like leaving notes for
people in this place yeah
none of them are around anymore I'll
just say proclick yeah so nice when you
get to a safe room yeah you breathe just
on edge the whole time like every corner
I turn and I'm waiting for it and I'm
equally never prepared okay
para masks what do you think about
resident evil 3 nemesis remake that'd be
fun I'm hoping that's the next move well
Resident Evil 8 and then remake of three
cuz that's the last one that needs to be
remade fors already been not remade but
for is good vibes good six they're all
HD you know
yes another one that's that quick turn I
need some space good jockey job wait
wait you gotta be bad I know why oh
there you go whoo
they take ways a mini shot yeah that's
like a lot but they're hard to dodge to
you gotta like make up your mind quick
when you encounter your guns all dirty
cloud says I hear a resident evil 3
remake is already in the works that be
do yeah they're always working a Capcom
I'm sure they got something going
already you're right
sus I don't like this room why did it
immediately look up there the camera did
that on its own
oh man something's amazing your
honorable there give me a lot of ammo
which means I'm in favor tactics
scratchy yes and a lockpick yeah the
Rumba keeps on giving what the wind plan
was that he and herb think that was me
where's there I thought I saw down there
yeah okay
some more cameras oh wait what was my
flashlight I think it like Otto did that
didn't it I don't remember
maybe my three witness doesn't work
there you go another tricky door all
right well let's try it let's attempt to
make our way back Adam asks why would it
be okay
no no this is great
yeah we need them all to drop like Adam
I don't think they'd remake Resident
Evil 1 just yet because they had so I
don't know if they're gonna touch
missing evil one for awhile that's just
my guess though it got like kind of a HD
upgrade not so much a remake we'll see
though that'd be cool a full-blown
Resident Evil 1 remake would be great
yeah wait of course now I'm 1 million
percent loss
oh yeah Matt here we go forget them bad
you're back in the house okay scorpion
key time I know I hear stuff
I should be able to use on this oh yeah
yeah woody alright we're back okay it's
a shortcut back to the main home where
his home way guys I know he's he's
lurking oh this is open all right so we
can go in here now which is it yeah is
there anything else I need to find
yeah Adam that's what I was saying they
remade it once from the ps1 to the
Gamecube that well that was a big
difference and then they later on they
put that one on the ps4 and like gave it
the HD remaster that remake yeah there
yeah Kevin wheeler is this great game
this is one of the greats for sure this
is a very scary game to play by yourself
it would be less embarrassing alone
you're doing great and we have a crowd
here you're doing great grain he's not
sitting there anymore I know I guess my
next goal would be to find the snake key
yeah need some more answers although I'm
hearing footsteps
maybe I need to find like a log or
something I can put here we have in your
inventory like is there any we have the
key tape which door is right along that
one tear right I think was it was that a
scorpion Oh near my I'm sorry I flipped
around there's a scorpion door in this
room I think oh yeah we just came out
okay yeah dang give me more keys and
more parts hey remember the pendulum
earlier you got to do a hot swap oh you
just safety box remember those forget
what the nearest one was though there
you go and then you meet some room
oh yeah wait where's the see come on no
time to talk now we add I'm going this
way you can't get me in here
whoo no asks what do you think of the
DLC for this game I thought it was good
maybe not great because it's it's a
little different from the main story
it's a lot more action because you play
as someone else with like a machine gun
you know but it's good and I you know I
wanted more of this game so I I got it
with the DLC it was good what do you
think of this one so far or yeah I
actually like it because from the
Resident Evil's I've played it's
definitely different
definitely yeah because it's more just
like FES like shooters out or you know
not if yes but it's like you know
shooter games don't oh yeah I don't want
to do this oh I wanted to go to
inventory okay there you go you can
throw some stuff in here yeah Mia's
creepy tape then I still need the scribe
yank even I I'm not sure anymore I think
you get a little X mark if you use it
all the way already so I would hang on
to that
I have one shotgun Chuck you put that
way if you want because you don't have
the shot crane yes Jordan Jones you can
combine but when your gun has a green
number like that it means it's fully
loaded Jordan so was Jordan Jones says
the fridge has stuff did you come across
a fridge I think there was one okay okay
Oh squares to move I was like I need to
create I like doing that too yeah I hate
like going downstairs this whole house
is creepy for round three be upstairs
they need to Marie Kondo this place yeah
this place does not spark joy yeah it's
scary the whole house there's no joy
here okay so where was the first
pendulum in the dining room area right
right okay you got that sounds like one
of the next big moves
that'll do something for sure yes I
grabbed the pendulum from here and go
back to that little living room but
homeboy was busy you can cut through
here now I think was the clock
and I reason what was I think you were
just stepping on debris you got the duck
one of the dogs hands
okay okay no shut up
he wouldn't think to come to this side
of the house you got your gun chat what
is your favorite resume you all games
let me know mine is too and I love the
remake of too and then a close second is
this and then probably four I love for
also where did he go man I hate this guy
come on Jack beat it right now get out
of here gonna do this kind of happens in
the Resident Evil and resen evil - you
have someone similar following you he's
not like a human like this but he's like
this weird bio-weapon human thing and
it's similar vibes alright so I was in
the fridge earlier I didn't say anything
there's no time
maybe another oh what was that little
it's just so close it yeah I think there
is a fridge later on that does have
something he was onto something but who
Chad is saying res evil for our
favorites some we got some love for
resin evil 3 stingray says I only played
four and five four is good Fight Club is
good - you should definitely check this
one out this is seven Oh
I can't believe this is full-speed
that's so annoying it's so creepy secret
place okay we're good
mark says mr. X yep that's the guy who
chases you 42 same vibe shutting you
down but he sees me watch him bust up a
basket okay so I got the dog head yes I
think that's that's where the front door
and you need it I think oh there's
another fridge oh hey so did was that
Remi opening the fridge I think so me if
it was sticky
cuz that freaking gave me a heart attack
oh you got some canned fluid some beer
empty beer
we should have beer that would calm us
down huh yeah agreed
okay oh so because I died and I didn't
get this stuff again Kevin says his
favorites are four and seven Thanks
tomorrow tomorrow says Code Veronica two
and three great choices I love Code
Veronica I forgot all about it it's been
so long since I played I feel like I
have more breathing room on this side
yeah yep Eddie says we need a resident
evil or remake a full blown remake I
mean I would definitely play it I loved
for so much so as it is yeah
like what would you remake about it
though yeah it's kind of a new already
pretty good isn't damn good but so was
too although it took forever to you know
remake that game - like what are you
years all right Travis
oh man he got you a little bit he did
good knock him out is he says love this
game same this is purchase first time
playing okay so we got Sean and Travis
yeah we we got body he gone incinerated
[Music]
okay now he opened that last one or was
it like a that's just someone I forget
how it goes
joe says resin evil to remake and seven
are the best and it's a three you see
like three also those are great choice I
love all these games man there's no
wrong answer you guys Joe also says
blocking is important it's hard man when
you're freaking out it's hard to defend
yep that's right mark Xbox one and ps4
got a resin evil for HD release that's
the one I have I bought it as soon as it
came out cuz it it was like pretty cheap
I was like twenty bucks
easy in the chat says good luck version
[Music]
the wrong way I'm good good I need space
[Music]
the Stingray says no one said their
favorite was resin you got your hand
back
he's ergh in the chat I think I said
your name right probably there is a
wrong answer Resident Evil survivor that
game is that game was tough did I go too
far away from its quiet yeah I think you
maybe he'll respond or did I yeah well
did you make that noise
I think this OH
does my gunshot okay I was like
I hurt I went in a circle
mark says the best part of Resident Evil
is that Resident Evil 4 chainsaw
controller oh my god that thing you got
this burger good locket block Wacka they
jumped me there were two yeah you
surrounded clinton oh alright we have
reached our time limits that's it but i
was definitely having a great time I was
in trouble right there he's got you got
to meet the mold oh man
that was fun definitely more scarier
than and then the Resident Evil's I've
played yep you're at a loss for words I
know I can't even like finish this out
show guys thank you for tuning in that
was super fun we're halfway through our
eight days of horror and we've got some
other pretty cool horror games on the
menu for the rest of the following days
yeah um I don't think we'll be able to
continue our a days until next week
though because extra life starts
tomorrow right so please tune in
tomorrow starting tomorrow I believe at
noon and where you're trying to raise
some money for a good cause
so please tune in it's gonna be a lot of
fun and next week we will pick up where
we left off with our eight days of
horror and also get hyped for some
Halloween action yeah we had a ton of
fun thanks for bearing with me and see
me freak out the entire time great and I
hope you guys have a great Thursday
we're one more day away from the weekend
yes hang in there hang in there you can
survive alright peace out you guys bye